[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
FLORA KLISE: Today, I am
going to be giving you
a full run-through of the
Singapore-Malaysia water
conflict.
This is something I knew
nothing about before the class
but I've really enjoyed learning
more about during this process
and applying the things
we've learned in the class
this semester.
So, please, ask questions
if things are not clear.
I can't promise
I have an answer,
but I'm excited to
share what I've learned.
So these are the things I'm
going to run through today,
basically give you an overview
of the case, then dive
into the water
resources for both areas
and the key
stakeholders, as well
as a brief overview
of the agreements,
and then try to spend the bulk
of the presentation talking
about the water
diplomacy framework
and how I see room
for improvement.
So this is a map
of the region, just
in case you're not familiar with
this part of Southeast Asia.
So Malaysia is much
larger than Singapore.
And, for this case,
we're only considering
peninsular Malaysia,
which is on the left,
and, specifically, Johor,
which is the state that
is most southernmost.
And it's hard to tell
from this perspective,
but Singapore and Malaysia
are separated by a small water
body called the Johor Strait.
And connecting the two countries
physically is the Johor
Causeway, or more commonly
known as just the Causeway.
So a summary of this
case can be summed up
in these couple
of bullet points.
So current water agreements
regulate the importation
of raw water from Johor,
Malaysia, to Singapore
and importation of treated
water from Singapore to Johor.
So this map shows
a simple overview
of the Johor River basin.
And you can see the prominent
Johor River and the Linggiu
Reservoir.
And then the dotted
line represents
the series of pipes that
cross the Johor Strait.
There is also complex
river networks
that offshoot from
the main river,
as well as you can
see the Johor River
Barrage, which is something I'll
talk about a little bit more.
That was a joint project to
improve the water supply.
There have been four
main agreements signed
between the two parties,
and the last agreements
will expire in 2061.
That's a number that--
or year that's going
to come up a lot.
And, despite ongoing
negotiations since 1990,
they've still failed to
reach another agreement.
Singapore is classified
as water-stressed
and relies on water from
Johor to currently meet
40% of its water demand,
so extremely significant.
And they're unable to meet their
demand without this imported
water.
And a blossoming
issue is the fact
that Johor has increasing issues
with meeting its own water
demand due to a combination
of increased pollution
as well as droughts.
So, to talk about
Malaysian water resources,
Malaysia is fortunate to have
very abundant water resources.
Despite being so
close to Singapore,
it has quite a
different landscape.
It's covered in rainforests
and experiences heavy rainfall
almost all year.
Some Malaysian states do suffer
from chronic water shortages
while others are
experiencing surpluses.
So how is that possible?
Before 1992, state governments
had almost complete control
over surface water resources.
So I guess you can--
so, as a result,
there's been a lot
of issues of water
management between the state
government and the
federal government,
which has tried to become more
involved as more issues arise
across the states
that are common
and related to water resources.
Climate change and
droughts put Malaysia
at an increasing risk of
becoming water-stressed
in the next 50 years,
according to research
done by institutions such as
the World Resources Institute.
I used their Water
Risk Atlas a lot
to help shape my
projections for this case.
And I think it's
really important
to note that currently,
Malaysia, and specifically
Johor, has a lot of water
and could manage it more
efficiently to meet its needs.
But it's possible, even
managed efficiently,
they won't be able to
do so in the future.
And I think kind of
the biggest point
here is that Malaysia
does not manage its water
resources effectively
currently, which
is a big reason driving
why they're unable to meet
their water demand.
This includes insufficient
infrastructure
to collect rainfall,
extreme water
pollution due to unregulated
practices of mining,
logging, land development,
and sewage disposal.
They have almost no water
conservation efforts.
They're hesitant to invest in
alternative water resources,
so things like desalination
or wastewater reuse.
And, still, despite
all of these things
they have agreements in
place to export water
to both Singapore and Malacca.
So the image here
on the upper right
is from part of
a river in Johor,
and it was taken many years ago.
So it's actually much harder
to find natural river--
or water resources
that don't more
resemble that bottom
image, where there's just
a lot of pollution buildup
and very poor water quality.
So Singapore water resources
is quite the different story.
The main issue that
Singapore faces
is that it doesn't have
enough natural water
supply to support their
growing population and economy.
And, since 1965, when
Singapore and Malaysia
separated from their brief
union quite acrimoniously,
Singapore has made a
very extreme effort
to implement a
three-pronged strategy
to decrease their water
vulnerability and water
dependence, especially from
Malaysia, by 2061, when
their current agreements
are going to expire.
So this three-pronged
approach first
focused on optimizing
their domestic water
supply by building
dams and reservoirs.
They have built a total of
11 reservoirs in addition
to three that
existed before 1965.
These reservoirs
cover about half
of Singapore's total land area.
You can see in this
image in the upper right
a glimpse of where
the reservoirs are.
It's hard to tell, but
there's small colorful dots.
This is from 2014.
But these are all
the projects that
are started or finished having
to do with water catchment.
So, actually,
after 1986, there's
almost no opportunities to
increase their water catchment
just due to restrictions
and land area.
So they then turn to the second
two prongs of their strategy,
which includes securing
alternative water
supplies through seawater
desalination, wastewater
reuse--
which they're one of the most
advanced systems in the world.
They have a reclaimed water
program called NEWater--
and negotiating a new
agreement with Indonesia
for imported water.
I'm really not going to
focus on that third one,
because they haven't
reached an agreement yet.
But the other two
are part of their--
have currently already started
to be implemented and hope
to increase in the future.
And the final prong
of their approach
is to improve
water conservation.
So they also went at
this quite aggressively.
They added regulations as
well as monetary incentives
for individuals as
well as businesses.
They've made investments in new
water conservation technology
as well as improving
existing infrastructure
to decrease the amount
of water lost to leaks.
And then, they also launched
a large budget education
campaign.
So it was very successful.
Already, Singapore is
experiencing a 0.2% decrease
in water consumption per year
despite continued population
and economic growth,
so very impressive.
Most parts of the
world, especially
with developing
economies, are increasing
water consumption per capita,
so pretty interesting.
And then, here, this is a
slightly outdated infographic
published by Singapore's Public
Utilities Board, also known
as PUB, which shows
Singapore's plan for decreasing
the reliance on imported water
and increasing their reliance
on reclaimed water
from wastewater,
which is the NEWater campaign,
which currently supplies
30% of their water demand.
But they have ambitious
plans to be relying on it
for about up to 55% by 2060.
And then seawater
desalination is currently
10% of their water demand,
but they hope to be up to 30%
by 2060.
So, again, they're really--
I think the domestic
water supply is about 20%
and won't really change.
So they're hoping
that if they are
successful in this
three-pronged approach,
they wouldn't be
reliant on Malaysia.
But, as I mentioned at
the beginning, currently,
they're still 40% reliant
on water from Malaysia.
And it seems pretty
unlikely that they'll
be 100% independent
in just 40 years.
So, next, I want to talk
about the key stakeholders
in the water negotiations.
So I'm not very familiar with
the governmental structure
of Singapore and Malaysia.
So, based on my research
about the water conflict,
I'm going to show you the
stakeholders that stood out.
In my paper, I
mentioned more about
how media had a unique
role in the water conflict.
Basically, news about water
negotiations and agreements
were widely covered in the local
newspapers in both Singapore
and Malaysia, where
the newspapers were not
only publishing
factual news coverage.
There is also increasingly
negative partisan editorials
and letters that were shared.
So this, combined with
the lack of transparency
from both governments,
went so far as--
like, one point, the
governments were just
communicating with each
other through the newspapers.
So one government
official in Singapore
read a Malaysian newspaper
with a public statement
from a Malaysian
official that had not
been talked about officially
behind closed doors.
So then, they had to release
a different statement
to their local
newspapers and on and on.
So it is quite
complex and something
that I didn't want
to muddle this idea,
but it meant that there's a lot
of stakeholders with opinions
about the negotiations
that are not at the table,
so people or groups representing
ecology as well as competing
minority political groups
in both territories.
So, here, we're going to
talk about the Malaysian key
stakeholders, which are
stakeholders from both the
federal and state governments.
So much of Malaysia's
water management
happens at the state level.
However, Malaysia's political
relationship with Singapore
inherently involves
federal stakeholders.
So that would be people
like the prime ministers.
Later, I'll mention that a
change in Malaysian leadership
will improve negotiations.
So that's due to Prime Minister
Mahathir Mohamad, whose picture
is placed on the
right, because he
was a driving force preventing
further water agreements
from being reached during his
position as prime minister.
And, unfortunately
for water diplomacy,
he governed two times
separately and basically has
a very primary focus
on water pricing
and wanting to increase
water prices for Singapore.
And, unfortunately, a focus
on competitive pricing
is just not conducive
to progress.
So, anyway, the National Water
Council and the National Water
Resources Council were
created in the 1990s
to improve water management,
specifically between the state
and federal levels.
But I would say, overall,
Malaysia's water management
is still relatively disorganized
and ultimately ineffective.
And that's just a challenge
that will need to be addressed.
And then, finally, the BAKAJ
is a Malaysian counterpart
of the PUB, which is the
Singapore Public Utilities
Board that runs their
water management.
So, currently, BAKAJ and
PUB have monthly meetings
to discuss water topics.
Quickly, to go over the
Singaporean key stakeholders,
as I've mentioned
several times now,
their management is led by the
PUB, which was founded in 1963
and is part of the Ministry of
Sustainability and Environment
in Singapore.
Publicly, the Singaporean
prime ministers, and more
recently, the minister
of foreign affairs,
Minister Vivian, has
been quite involved
in the diplomatic
relations with Malaysia.
And they're the
ones who would be
responsible for signing
any official agreements
between Malaysia and Singapore.
So, in my paper, I have a
pretty in-depth description
of the terms of all four water
agreements between Singapore
and Malaysia.
But, for the sake
of time, I'm going
to highlight the main points
that you need to understand.
So, starting in 1927, Singapore
rented a plot of land in Johor
at an annual rate and
then can use all the water
found in and on the land.
In return, Johor would
buy back specific amounts
of treated water from Singapore.
An interesting thing to note
is that this agreement allowed
for increases in land and
treated water purchased
and traded, expecting that
the water needs would change
and they would probably
want to increase that.
So they specifically
wrote that in.
The 1961 and 1962 agreements
replaced the 1927 agreement.
They expanded the amount
of resources that would
be traded between the two.
They defined a certain
rate at which the prices--
the water would be bought.
So, in this agreement, Singapore
would buy water, raw water,
from Johor at 3 sen
per 1,000 gallons,
while Malaysia would
buy treated water
for 50 sen per 1,000 gallons.
So I mention that
because the agreements
both include a joint price
review every 25 years.
Unfortunately, none of the
times that they've met--
so I think the last one
was in 1986 and 1987--
they weren't able to
reach any update even
though an update was necessary.
It's like both sides kept asking
for a little bit too much.
So, as a result, they
got no agreement.
So, to this day,
the water is still
being sold for 3 sen per
1,000 gallons and 50 sen.
So that would really
come back later
when I talk about
what needs to be done.
And, finally, the 1990
agreement was an extension
of the 1962 agreement.
It authorized a new
construction of another dam.
Singapore has made a lot of
infrastructure investments
in Johor to increase
their water supply
but also benefits the local
Johor community, and completely
at the Singaporean expense.
I guess, to sum up, the one
agreement expired in 2011,
and then there's two
that are still active.
But, again, they were
not able to renew
the one that expired in 2011.
So, as a result, Singapore had
to decrease the amount of water
they imported from Malaysia.
A couple of supplemental things
that you might care about
is the 1965
Separation Agreement,
which is also known as the
Independence of Singapore
agreement.
And it included a clause
ensuring that Malaysia would
abide by the terms of
the water agreements
already signed to ensure
Singapore's water security.
And this was filed with
the United Nations.
The 1998 through 2003
water pricing negotiations
were a time when Malaysia
and Singapore were trying
to negotiate another agreement
that would last for 100 years
to extend this deadline of 2061.
Malaysia was motivated
because they needed finances
from Singapore to back
their currency because there
was a financial crisis.
And Singapore just wanted
to secure water resources
for an extended period of time.
Once Malaysia no longer
needed the finances
because they got it
from somewhere else,
the negotiations were reduced
to debates about the water
pricing, packaging
the water, policies
with other partisan issues,
and just got out of control.
In these negotiations,
Malaysia tried
to increase the
price of raw water
from 3 sen per 1,000
gallons to 45 sen, then 60
sen, and finally, 625 sen
per 1,000 gallons in 2002.
And, as you might expect,
no agreement was made.
Finally, I highlight the
Johor River Barrage project,
which was a three-year
project funded by Singapore
and addressed the saltwater
intrusion to the Johor River
Basin.
So that's an example
of both Johor
and Singapore were suffering
from a reduced quality of water
in the river basin.
So Singapore agreed
to fund a project that
would improve these and ensure
a longer-term water resource.
So now, I would love to talk
about the water diplomacy
framework and how this fits in.
So the Singapore-Malaysia
water conflict
is unique because
there's only two parties
involved, sharing
water resources that
are not physically common.
The water networks are
defined through several water
agreements where water is being
traded rather than shared.
However, Johor and Singapore
still mutually benefit
from the terms of the
existing agreements,
and they have acknowledged
that publicly.
The water diplomacy framework
acknowledges the complexity
of managing competition,
feedback, and interconnection
between the natural and
societal domains in the context
of the political domain.
So that is absolutely true.
In this circumstance, there
were ongoing societal tensions
between Singaporean and
Malaysian communities
at every level over a lot
of issues, not just water.
And then, Johor has been
experiencing increasing water
problems in the natural domain
related to water quantity
as well as quality, which
threatens both stakeholders.
And, finally, because
the media was so involved
in covering the
water negotiations,
the group of stakeholders
with opinions
is actually much larger
than the officials
that are involved in the
signing of the agreements.
And, as a result, there's
kind of a negative air
around the agreements and
signing a new agreement.
So something that I
recognized immediately
is that there would
need to be trust
built between the stakeholders.
So the first issue that
needs to be addressed
is how to build this trust
and enhance cooperation
between the different
stakeholders, mainly
state government officials.
And, before negotiations
can make progress,
stakeholders from
both sides will
need to recognize and
accept the value of being
cooperative rather
than competitive,
which is something we talked
a lot about in this class.
So one of the stickiest points
in the current negotiations
is the water pricing
for the raw water
bought by Singapore and the
treated water bought by Johor.
However, both
Singapore and Johor
have increasing concerns
about their water security.
So I think it'd be really
beneficial to shift
the conversations away
from competitive water
pricing that's motivated
by self-interest
and start by discussing
cooperative strategies
for making sure that
both parties will have
enough water of
the right quality,
because the opportunities
for mutual gains
would then be more prioritized,
which is what, obviously, they
both need.
So I guess I will note that
there are ongoing negotiations
and conversations and
meetings between Singapore
and Malaysian officials.
So I think things that have
been highlighted is they have
an annual leaders' retreat,
which is literally just
a retreat for their
leaders to meet,
joint ministerial committee
meetings that happen on monthly
and yearly basis, the ministers
of both countries visit
the other country to
improve relations,
and then they've recently
created the Malaysia-Singapore
Joint Committee on
the Environment,
which is also basically
for this kind of--
to increase the relations
in these topics.
So there's starting
to be progress,
but it's really
not being reflected
in any legislative
progress, in my opinion.
This is something that I thought
was interesting to point out.
So most partisan media
articles from both sides
reflect slightly different
versions of the same story.
So Malaysian media
articles would
say that the current
agreements only benefit
Singaporean stakeholders.
Johor is experiencing increasing
incidents of water scarcity.
And Singapore just
keeps taking the amount
that it's always agreed upon
despite the circumstances
changing.
The water pricing
has not been updated.
And, as a result, Singapore is
getting this raw water at way
below the price that they
should be buying it at.
And then, conservative
Singaporean media outlets
would frame the issue
quite differently.
But it's ultimately
the same story,
where Singapore has
been actively trying
to reduce its reliance
on water from Johor
while continuously granting
requests from Johor for more
treated water than agreed
upon in the agreements
at the same discounted rates.
This is just to maintain
goodwill between the two
parties.
And Singapore has prioritized
enhancing their water security
by extending the
water agreements.
However, if Johor
wants to increase
the price of raw
water, Singapore
would have to increase the
price of treated water.
So this slide is
basically to go over
how both sides, if you
look at it objectively,
could be gaining from
this relationship.
I chose this image.
This is a screenshot from the
Aqueduct Water Risk Atlas tool
that I mentioned before.
This is their projection
for water risk in Singapore
and Johor in 2040 if
things continue, quote,
"business as usual."
So, as you can
tell, Singapore is
classified as
extremely high risk,
and Johor is medium
to high risk.
So, for reference, currently,
if you click to baseline,
both are classified as low risk.
So this is something where their
water risk characteristics are
increasing due to changes
in climate change, drought,
and pollution.
So, currently, Singapore
and Johor rely on each other
to meet their water demands.
They both care about the
decreasing water quality
in Malaysia since it
jeopardizes both water security
of Singapore and Malaysia.
I recognize that Singapore has
much more and better experience
in launching water
conservation campaigns
as well as investing in
alternative water supplies.
They have one of
the most advanced
systems in the world for
desalination and water reuse,
as well as very strict
water quality tactics
because they don't want
to waste their own water.
So I think that's
one opportunity where
both nations could
benefit if Singapore could
give some of their
experience and help improve
the situation in Malaysia.
Secondly, both parties are
unsure of the long-term effects
of climate change and drought
on their water security.
So they both want to be
resilient and prepared to adapt
to changing water circumstances.
The water prices for both the
raw water and the treated water
are absolutely outdated
and should be updated.
However, that should not
be the only thing included
in the conversation, because
that is currently only
representing self-interest.
Singapore benefits from
Johor's water supply
to support its economic growth.
It needs the water.
And, while they say that they
will be independent by 2061,
that has not been proven.
And I think, furthermore, an
ongoing water relationship
for Singapore is convenient
because Singapore has already
made long-term
infrastructure investments
and already have good existing
relationships with the water
representatives there.
So, rather than trying to find
a different importing place
to get water from,
it makes sense
that Singapore would want
to stick with Malaysia.
And, finally,
Malaysia would benefit
because they need the increased
supply of treated water,
and they need assistance
stimulating progress
in increasing their
supply long-term,
since they have no
progress in water treatment
development, water conservation
development, or water pollution
regulation.
So, finally, a couple of other
ways that the water diplomacy
framework could be
utilized include utilizing
an impartial moderator.
So it was really successful
when they lodged the document
with the UN after
they split politically
to ensure that Malaysia would
not renege on their agreement.
And I'm really confused why
they haven't done that since.
It seems like incorporating
some more impartial stakeholders
could really help
promote progress.
And, secondly, I think
it'd be interesting
if they would
start conversations
about signing a new agreement,
unrelated to the water
supply but kind of more
toward a joint agreement,
trying to become more resilient
in the face of climate change.
This part of the world
is extremely vulnerable.
And if Singapore,
Malaysia and some
of these other southeastern
Asian countries and states
join together in their efforts
to develop new technology
and get better information, it
would really benefit them all.
So, yeah, these are
the key takeaways.
But I think, just
for the sake of time,
it's pretty clear that
Singapore and Malaysia already
recognize that their agreements
are mutually beneficial.
However, they have not been able
to reach further agreements,
which is threatening both
the water security of both,
and ultimately, preventing
progress and security.
DR. GAIN: Thank you, Flora,
for the nice presentation.
It's really wonderful.
So yeah, is there any feedback
for Flora, Husnain or Cassiano?
AUDIENCE: Well, well done for
your wonderful presentation.
As this topic was new for you,
you have done a very great job.
Just first of all, let me
give you a small comment.
As you mentioned a
prospect for desalination,
my view would be that
desalination is expensive
and its production is
energy-intensive and involves
carbon emissions.
In the long run,
Malaysia might not
be able to operate and
maintain it as well.
As you mentioned
in the case study
that Malaysia has had some
availability of fresh water
and receives ample rainfall, it
would be better for Singapore
to cooperate and invest
in water infrastructure,
enhancing Malaysia's
storage capacity, which,
in turn, would ensure long-term
water security for Singapore.
And Malaysia could, in turn,
offer increased water quality
to Singapore.
This could be a practical
mutual gains approach in respect
to the water
diplomacy framework.
And, secondly,
the question would
be that what is the public
sentiment in Malaysia
given their own water
scarcity situation?
You mentioned that
some states receive--
are water scarce.
And you mentioned that,
as per the treaty,
water flows freely to Singapore.
But some states within
Malaysia face water scarcity.
So what is the public sentiment
within Malaysia about that?
FLORA KLISE: I can
respond to that.
Yeah, so definitely, the public
response is pretty negative.
I think it's negative
in every regard.
It's like we want to sell
the water to Singapore,
but they need to
pay us way more.
We want to sell it to them,
but they're not paying enough.
And then, it's also like, why
are they taking our water when
we don't have enough water?
That's not fair either.
So I think part of that
is unavoidable just
because, yes, Singapore
also needs the water,
and it's confusing.
But I think the public
sentiment is tainted
by political sentiment that's
just Malaysians don't like
Singaporean as a stereotype
but then further aggravated
by this increased water scarcity
caused by these droughts
and lack of rain capture.
So yeah, it definitely
is negative and not
very controlled.
The information
shared in Malaysia
is not the same information
shared in Singapore.
Media is extremely
regulated in both countries
and is highly partisan.
So, as a result, it's really
hard to change public opinion.
But, from what I
understand, the public
doesn't have much control
over what happens, so.
AUDIENCE: And just
one more thing.
You know, as you mentioned,
that the treaty expires in 2061.
And it is still four decades
until the existing treaty
is going to expire.
And some clarity is
required why negotiations
are needed to extend--
why negotiations have already
started as of now because it
is still four decades remaining.
Or the two countries are trying
to formalize a new treaty
before 2061 in order to get
it for existing water scarcity
and water quality issues.
FLORA KLISE: Yeah, so basically,
from their point of view,
40 years is not long at all.
In the early 2000s,
they were trying
to negotiate a treaty that
would last for 100 years,
so extend it from 2061
to more like 3001.
It sounds so weird to say.
But, yeah, they were
unable to reach one.
But, basically,
especially for Singapore,
since this is more of an
issue of water security
in the next 40
years, if, in 2061,
they aren't able to import
water from Malaysia anymore,
and they have not succeeded in
increasing their water reuse
and water desalination,
basically, Singapore
will no longer be
able to supply water
to run its municipal and
industrial water supply.
So that, I guess, is the
threat of water security.
And some parties would even
say, what would they do?
Would they try to
fight Malaysia,
some kind of water war?
Most people say no.
But that's basically why it's
so urgent, why they don't want
to wait until 10 years before,
because, already, negotiations
have been going on
for 30 years, and they
haven't reached any agreement.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Wonderful
presentation, Flora.
Every time I have a
question in my mind,
your next slide
answered my question.
It was very good.
Flora, do you think that
Indonesia could be considered
a partner for Singapore?
FLORA KLISE: Well,
it seems like they'll
run into the same
issues that they're
running into with Malaysia
but having a little bit
less bad blood.
And it's extremely
less convenient
since, already, Singapore
has invested so much
in the Malaysian water resources
that, if they were going
to do the same
thing in Indonesia,
it would be like
starting from scratch
and also probably ruin their
relationship with Malaysia,
decrease their chances of
renewing the water agreements.
So I think, in that regard,
it's been quite hard.
Also, the main thing
holding up any negotiations
is that Indonesia has had
a lot of political turmoil
internally.
So just the lack
of governance has
prevented real conversations
from happening.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Flora, if you know more
about this innovation,
can you talk about the four
taps and the NEWater solutions?
FLORA KLISE: Yeah.
So Singapore has one
of the most developed--
I mean, Larry and
Animesh can stop me
if I'm just saying wrong
things-- but a very advanced
water recycling program.
So NEWater is what
they're calling it.
I have a manager
from my internship
that lives in Singapore,
and she always
laughs at me when she says,
like, in your country,
you call reclaimed
water toilet to tap.
And she's like,
that sounds gross.
No wonder no one likes it.
She's like, in Singapore,
we call it NEWater.
Everyone wants new water.
NEWater sounds great
and cool and innovative.
She's like, toilet to tap?
That's bad advertising.
So yeah, basically,
they've really
worked on increasing their
reclaimed water supply.
They have very
advanced technology
to do water reuse, which
is a technology that's not
utilized very much in the US.
There's not as much
technology development
in the US because of this
hesitancy from the public
and industry to adopt it.
But that is what
they're mainly relying
on where, instead of
getting rid of wastewater,
you'd be able to recycle it one
or two times to use it again,
which obviously makes sense.
And then, seawater desalination
is their other big technology
push for their four taps, other
than the rainfall capture,
since that is basically
just exhausted.
They don't have any more
land to expand into.
So yeah, I think Husnain
raised a good point.
Desalination is expensive.
It currently relies
on carbon fuel
and will wear out,
potentially, if it's not
maintained properly.
So yeah, I think
that's interesting.
I haven't really
read any articles.
Right now, Singapore is
just really in the push
to increase the amount of
water that they are obtaining
from non-Malaysian sources
AUDIENCE: Thank you
very much, Flora.
Congratulations again.
FLORA KLISE: Thanks.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: I just
want to annotate the question
of desal a little bit.
Desalination now is
completely solar-powered.
And the Israelis have created
very advanced desalination
technologies, again,
for their own uses.
Israel is going to be almost
85% desal in the next decade,
even though they have water.
They have aquifers.
But they're not going
to hold out forever.
And Israel has developed
new technologies
for separating the brine
from the fresh water.
Kuwait is 95% desal.
Everything in the country,
95% of the water is in desal.
So yes, it was true that desal
was mostly fossil fuel-driven.
It isn't-- no one planning a
future desal facility of large
scale would think, unless they
were an oil-generating country
and had so much extra oil they
didn't know what else to do,
but that isn't the
case in Singapore.
I personally think that
Singapore will have no problem
through recycling.
People have to understand that
Malaysia and Singapore think
of themselves as
developed countries.
They do not think of
themselves as developing.
They have the most
advanced technology.
advanced universities.
Singapore has used
advanced technology
on just about everything.
And, because it is a
small island nation,
it has the limitations,
as was nicely pointed out,
of scale in terms of land.
But it's going to
be able to claim
existing space at its edges
and expand development
on the water.
And my sense is that
it's not crazy to think
that Singapore, through desal--
because it's got all of
this area on the ocean--
and water recycling,
which is the most
advanced in the world
for municipal systems,
and a space that
can't grow in terms
of large additional population,
and it can't increase density
because it's already
as high as Manhattan.
So my sense is that they've
made some smart choices.
And I think they will
take advantage of water
from Malaysia when they
need it as they need it.
The other thing
that has to be noted
is that Johor is a
state in Malaysia,
but Malaysia has two parts.
The peninsula part that you
talked about is in one place.
And the other two states,
it's like Hawaii and Alaska
for Americans.
The other two states
are on top of Borneo.
They're on top of
another country
as far away as Hawaii
is from San Francisco.
And those two states are
amongst the most important
income-generating states
because that's where
all the natural resources are.
And so the water
policy in Malaysia
doesn't really focus
on the two states
that are separate, because
there's very few people there--
I mean comparatively--
and plenty of water.
So the water issues are in
the peninsula of Malaysia.
And my sense is that
there's plenty of water.
I'm a little less
negative, I think, Flora,
than you are about their
pollution improvements
over the last decade.
In all of their cities where
the rivers run through the city,
they got the idea
from San Antonio.
Instead of covering
over the river
and just dumping everything in
it, they uncovered the river
and they made it an
attraction of the city, which
meant they had to do
the pollution cleanup.
And the level of
pollution cleanup--
I've been working in
Malaysia for a decade.
And, even from year
one to year seven,
the difference in
pollution levels in rivers
is really dramatic.
And the coordination,
which I understand--
when you look and
do research on this,
the coordination between the
federal level and the state
levels is dramatically enhanced
in the last five years.
Now, they had this crazy
change of governments.
And now, they're back to a
normal kind of government
that has qualified people
in senior positions.
There was a period
a few years ago,
where the transition happened,
where the people running
stuff were political
appointees with zero
professional background
and capabilities.
But now things
are back in order.
So I think there's a
chance of the negotiations.
Since a friend of mine is
the head of the commission
and will be doing
the negotiations,
I think there's a
chance that they
will find all of these mutual
benefits that you point out.
Johor, it has all
these facilities
being built by Singapore.
The national government
is saving the money,
and Johor is saving the money.
And, if Singapore is willing
to build all these facilities,
and if Singapore continues
to increase its own water
resources, it won't be so
scary about its long-term need
for all of Johor's water.
Two other things that
have happened maybe
since the material you were
looking at was published.
One is that a
Chinese developer has
built a new city floating in
the Straits of Johor right
between Johor--
and Malaysia and Singapore.
And it's Malaysian.
So Singapore is quite distressed
about it, especially because--
and this is the other thing.
You had it on the slide,
but you need to explain it.
Malaysia is a democracy,
but it also is a monarchy.
And so we're used to
thinking about how
the British government operates.
Well, the sultans-- there are
six sultans, six sultanates,
within Malaysia.
And, each year, one of them
is the sultan of sultans.
And the sultanate is
in the Constitution
and has a variety of
things that it controls.
And the sultan of Johor is a
player in the conversation,
even though it's
country to country,
because the sultan has real
say within what Malaysia does.
Malaysia is a
Muslim country, even
though Chinese and Indian
populations are growing.
It's basically a Muslim country.
And all of the original
settlers came from Indonesia.
And so there are implicit
connections to Indonesia.
But Indonesia is
a long way away.
How are you going to get water?
You're not going to have a
pipe from Indonesia to Johor.
That's nuts.
So my sense is that
you're exactly on target,
that they need to do something
about these negotiations
quickly.
And there are plenty of
joint gains to be had.
But the negotiation
will include Johor,
even though it's a state.
I think they ought to encourage
the involvement of Malacca,
which is another
state which isn't
a sultanate in the same
way and would benefit
by being part of the deal.
And I think we should expect
that solar-powered desal will
be very important in producing
maybe 40% or 50% of everything
that they need into the
future and that recycling
and this huge construction
of all of these reservoirs--
it's amazing.
A tiny little island
built 11 big reservoirs
to capture rainwater because
they saw this problem coming.
So they're not in
terrible shape.
Malaysia is not
in terrible shape.
There are advantages to be had.
Yes, the pricing is
going to have to change.
But there's so much shared
interest in other things
that the last thing I would
expect is a water war.
They don't have an army.
So that would make a difference.
Malaysia does, but my
sense is that these two
nations and Johor will be
able to figure this out.
But you do a beautiful
job of describing
the history of identifying
why these negotiations are
important.
The older negotiations
were in a different time,
before you had such
powerful economic countries.
These were developing countries.
Now they are developed
nations with lots of money.
And they should be able
to deal with each other.
So I think your emphasis
is just right that.
The only two things
I would point out,
which I think the threat of
doing something with Indonesia
is nuts just because of
distance and because Indonesia
has its own problems
to worry about.
And I think-- and I think this
floating city, Forest City--
that's what they called
it, Forest City--
700,000 people on
floating platforms
in wetland, in an
internationally protected
wetland.
It's a disaster.
And so that's what led to the
new joint effort on environment
and sustainability, which
is Malaysia never should
have allowed it to happen.
But the national government
defers on land use issues
to the state.
And the sultan of Johor is
one of the major investors
in this ridiculous,
gigantic new city.
And he was in it for the
money, and it was his land.
And, because he owned
the speck of island,
he didn't need to get
any permissions to build.
And the Chinese developer
was happy to fill.
And so they filled
everything, and it created--
it killed all of the
fishing industry up and down
the strait.
And oh, this was a mistake.
And they had to dig it out,
and they had to re-go back,
and they did this
through court action
because Singapore brought
suit against Malaysia.
And the Malaysian
government sheepishly
said, well, it was the state.
We didn't know what
they were doing.
And this project is the
largest planned community
by a Chinese developer
outside of China.
And it's a gated
community for Chinese.
But it's going to use all the
water and all the services
and everything else from Johor.
There's so many things
about it which is--
but it's created the
need for the Malaysia
national government and
Singapore national government
to work together on--
they are alleging
it's climate change.
It's on sustainable development
and the protection of wetlands
and the protection
of other resources.
Sorry to go on.
It's just-- I think you
did a beautiful job.
I'm delighted you
chose the subject,
and we'll be able to put
this in the collection
because it's an important
example of nations
where states within
nations really are players.
So this nation-to-nation
treaty thing,
the agreement isn't
going to happen
without Johorian involvement.
And it involves all
kinds of technology.
Anyway, I think you
did a great job, Flora.
FLORA KLISE: Thanks so much.
DR. GAIN: Yeah.
So thanks, Flora.
It was a wonderful presentation.
And I think, in
terms of improvement,
in terms of exploration,
you did an excellent job
as I read your draft paper.
And I already made comments
I already sent to you.
But, in the presentation,
you incorporated the water
diplomacy framework very well.
But, in the paper, it was not,
so maybe we'll work on that.
And so maybe, for the
implementing water diplomacy
framework, if you just
focus on the conflict--
in my view, this
conflict now they're
stuck is that Malaysia is
demanding price increasing
and Singapore is not willing
to provide that much amount
for the raw water.
So, in that point, how you can--
yeah, so how this stuck can be--
dispositional things
can be improved
by these joint
factfinding things.
The issue that you
already mentioned,
if you just describe
in a way that
can provide a systematic
explanation of the things,
I think then the paper
could be fantastic.
It's already nice, but it can be
further improved in that part.
So yeah.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: I do
think, Flora, your tone
about the relationship
between these two countries
and its historical roots is
very, very true and very,
very important.
And one of the reasons is
that this really simple water
money--
recycled water
treaty-- isn't getting
fixed is Singapore doesn't want
to admit any need for anything
from Malaysia.
It's just-- it goes back
to when they pulled apart,
and Singapore felt it developed
itself as a developed nation.
And Malaysia took so
much longer and didn't
know how to do what they did.
And they don't want
to be beholden.
I have the advantage of
talking with the person who's
doing the negotiations for
Malaysia, who's a scientist,
and he thinks the whole
thing is ridiculous.
And he just doesn't understand.
What do you want?
[? Is ?] [? that ?] the price?
Come on.
Let's ask some independent folks
what the value of the water is
and the recycled water.
You've got a huge
amount of money.
It's not about the money.
And I think, by involving
more of the states,
it will be easier
for Singapore to say,
well, we did this because
we're helping those states,
because they just can't swallow
the idea of doing anything
for or needing Malaysia.
And I think you captured
that tone very appropriately
in your paper from the history.
FLORA KLISE: I think that's
one of the interesting parts
of reading so many
very partisan articles.
It's very clear-- it makes
it even more clear where
the gaps in communication
and pride and things
like that play in, because
it's just so obvious as someone
impartial.
You feel like the parent
watching your kids bicker.
You're like, you
can both have water.
You don't need to just say
the other person's ugly.
You can just take the water
and then call it a day.
So yeah, it was
very interesting.
There is not much literature,
but there's a lot of coverage.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: There's
a lot of coverage, yeah.
Well, people have
been discouraged.
Scholars have been discouraged
from writing about it quite
explicitly at University
in Singapore and University
of Technology in Malaysia
that I work with.
They've been told, don't do it.
You're killing your career if
you write anything scholarly
about this, because this isn't
really a scholarly issue.
And nobody wants--
FLORA KLISE: Hopefully, that
doesn't come bite me later.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Yeah.
But, for us, studying
water diplomacy
to understand that the root
issue is this historical not
just lack of trust, but really,
almost hatred of two parties
that were part of
the same country.
It's difficult.
And I think there's also--
partly, this is about the
fact that the Muslim majority
in Malaysia is, in some
ways, losing control.
It still gets who
it wants elected,
and it's still 51% Muslim.
And the Chinese,
though, are really
controlling industry
in Malaysia.
They're controlling
wealth in Malaysia,
whereas the Muslim
majority, bare majority,
is controlling government
in Malaysia and certain--
a few industries.
And it's-- Singapore is not
interested in acknowledging
the power of a Malaysian
partner who is Muslim.
They're much more
focused on Chinese.
And the Muslim
majority in Malaysia
thinks that the Chinese minority
is using its connections
to Singapore to build more
of its strength and power
in Malaysia and wants to take
over the government, which
has always been the domain
of the Muslim majority.
So all of these
pieces and parts,
these are part of
water diplomacy.
And I think your case is
important because it brings out
these are not just
about natural resource
management or territory.
This is about this lack of trust
in this difficult relationship
between the two
countries, which you do
a really nice job of raising.